we hear about those bullying allegations
and how that she was incredibly
difficult to work for at the palace but
i actually was very close with a lot of
their team and the people that worked
with them and megan often went out of
her way to help some of those people new
details have come to light regarding the
bullying accusations from former
employees of meghan markle as part of
the updated epilogue in the new
paperback release of omid scobee and
carolyn duran's finding freedom which
chronicles megan and prince harry's
decision to step down from their senior
roles in the royal family and according
to their sources those royal staffers
are taking back their bullying claims
the big story of course just days before
they sat down with oprah was that megan
was suddenly the office bully
terrorizing the younger staff at the
palace
and the royal households um to the point
where some of them would break down in
tears after spending moments around her
and you know immediately this sort of
raised my eyebrows just a little
refresher
allegations against the duchess of
sussex first came to light in an article
by the times back in march just days
before the couple's tell-all interview
with oprah winfrey at the time the
publication reported that megan was
facing a bullying complaint at
kensington palace claiming she quote
drove two personal assistants out of the
household and was undermining the
confidence of a third staff member
according to the article the complaint
was made in october 2018 by jason knopf
megan and harry's communication
secretary at the time quote seemingly in
an effort to get buckingham palace to
protect staff who he claimed were coming
under pressure from the duchess
the times also claimed harry pleaded
with jason not to pursue it but
according to finding freedom's new
epilogue sources confirmed that after
learning about jason's complaint two of
the individuals mentioned asked for any
allegations made to hr about their
experiences with megan to be rescinded
the book also claims that that whole
meeting between harry and jason never
even happened when we wrote this book we
got close to a lot of the people around
them and so for those things to have
never come up to us
um sort of immediately rang alarm bells
and you know someone close to megan said
to me at the time it felt like a kind of
uh oppo dump you know just before
presidential election you know the
opposition or sort of avengeful news
organization may throw everything they
can
at someone in the hopes that it will
discredit their character and i do
believe that that's what happened here
back in march a spokesperson for the
duke and duchess of sussex called the
story a quote calculated smear campaign
and megan's close friend janina gavankar
echoed that sentiment in a statement
published in finding freedom quote it
was without doubt done intentionally to
discredit the duchess i have known megan
for 17 years and i have seen the way she
regards people around her and the people
she works with and i can say she is not
a bully buckingham palace has since
launched an investigation into the
claims a move which sources say in
finding freedom was welcomed by the
couple but in june it was announced that
the results of the investigation were
being delayed the times first reported
that the investigation which is being
conducted by an independent law firm may
delay its verdict until next year and a
source told et at the time that the
investigation is still continuing as for
omid he tells et he hopes the book helps
to show megan in a different light
i've always found it really difficult to
marry up the sort of caricature of megan
and the tabloids to the person that i
was able to sort of watch
in front of me as a royal correspondent
and that
really is why we wanted to do this book
in the first place so people could
actually get a better idea of who not
just megan was but harry and megan were
and i hope that people feel like that
was achieved
[Music]